too often affairs are seen as the
outcome of random horniness or just
plain old nastiness but that's very
rarely the case when it comes to Affairs
we spend far too long being incensed or
secretive and far too little time trying
to understand
in truth Affairs stem from a very fiddly
aspect of our romantic psychology in
relationships with a partner all of us
need carefully calibrated mixtures of
two different ingredients we have a need
for closeness and a need for distance we
want in part closeness to feel we can
hug touch be cozy intimate and entirely
relaxed and at home with someone we want
them to know our thoughts and to wander
freely in their minds too but we also
need distance enough not to feel
cloyingly submerged subsumed or owned by
another we want to retain a sense of
freedom we need a private room to which
we alone have the key any imbalances
towards over closeness or over distance
may prove catastrophic if left
unaddressed in a relationship which
threatens to lean perilously towards
over closeness we can be driven to stray
by a powerful urge to prove to ourselves
that not everything we do in our is
owned by the partner that we remain
desirable to the world and a going
concern in and of ourselves going to bed
with a new person might not simply be
about lust
it's about escaping the alarming feeling
that one's whole identity appears to be
on the verge of dissolving into the
couple
but too much distance can undermine
fidelity no less powerfully the distance
reads like constant rejection when we
try to touch the partner they move away
or sigh when we bring up something
personal they change the subject we may
end up having an affair not because we
don't love the partner anymore but
precisely because we do and yet the
distance they appear to be imposing on
us through their lack of engagement
feels unendurable and humiliating
it's the final irony that if Court will
be accused of not caring when it was
caring too much that might have inspired
the whole mistake an escapade tragically
two people almost never enter a
relationship with the same needs for
distance or closeness that's why in
every couple we hear the accusation that
one person is too clingy and another is
too cold these are on helpfully vicious
words for what are at heart just two
different ways of feeling comfortable in
love it's there for an early imperative
in any relationship to work out what the
relative needs for distance and
closeness actually are to air the
disjuncture not to get angry about it
and mutually and with good humor to
apologize for one's distinctive
contribution to it only thus can we hope
to ensure that the gap won't lead in an
online chat at a bar or at a conference
to a situation where only an affair
feels like a plausible solution to the
vexing problems of distance and
closeness
you